I didn't like the old Twitter I don't
want someone saying you can't see what's
in this pipe I'm a big boy out I can
take it actually I don't like what
people say I can't take it but but in
general I want to see what people are
saying then let's stop pointing fingers
and let's start pointing thumbs right
like I can tell you right now my Twitter
and threads experience is phenomenal
because I choose to be practical and
optimistic I'm not delusional I'm not in
fairy land but I choose to see the
opportunities I choose to be
entrepreneurial I choose to be on the
offense I choose to not dwell on stuff
that I can't control and I definitely
have no interest in tearing down other
people or other operations or CEOs or
businesses to make myself feel better
there's two ways to build the biggest
building in town one tear down everybody
else's buildings two just be good enough
to build the biggest building I choose
the latter